WELL AS IRAN TRIES TO PUT DOWN
MONTHS OF PROTESTS, MORE PEOPLE
THAN WE KNEW ABOUT COULD BE
EXECUTED FOR THEIR INVOLVEMENT
IN THOSE PROTESTS.
CNN INVESTIGATION DONE WITH AN
ACTIVIST GROUP CALLED 1500
TESTS VIA, FOUND AT LEAST 43
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH
CRIMES PUNISHABLE BY DEATH.
AND THE REAL NUMBER COULD BE
MUCH HIGHER.
THEY INCLUDE A 26-YEAR-OLD
FOOTBALLER, HE IS ACCUSED OF
BEING INVOLVED IN THE KILLINGS
OF SECURITY OFFICERS DURING A
PROTEST.
IRAN'S JUDICIARY SAID FEWER
THAN A DOZEN PEOPLE HAVE
RECEIVED THE DEATH PENALTY OVER
THE UNREST, SO FAR WE KNOW
ABOUT TWO PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
PUBLICLY EXECUTED.
ON THE LEFT OF YOUR SCREEN YOU
CAN SEE IMAGERIES A RUN AVOWED
WITH HIS MOTHER, AND ON THE
RIGHT, MOHSEN SHEKARI.
FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF THOSE
AWAITING POSSIBLE EXECUTION ARE
BEGGING THE WORLD TO STEP IN
BEFORE IT IS TOO LATE.
CNN'S NIMA ELBAGIR BRINGS US
THIS EXCLUSIVE REPORT.
>> >> TRANSLATOR: MY SON HAS
BEEN SENTENCED TO EXECUTION.
>> MOHAMMAD ABOUT WHO IS ONLY
22.
>> TRANSLATOR: MY SON IS
INNOCENT, FOR THE LOVE OF GOD,
HELP HIM.
>> DESPERATE FAMILIES IN IRAN
RISKING IT ALL WITH A PLEA TO
THE WORLD TO SAVE THEIR LOVED
ONES FROM EXECUTION.
FEARING THAT DETAINEES IN IRAN
ARE SET TO FACE A WAVE OF
EXECUTIONS, AND ACCELERATED
USUAL PROCESS, WHILE HOLIDAY
CELEBRATIONS HAVE THE WORLD'S
ATTENTION ELSEWHERE.
IN COLLABORATION WITH IRANIAN
ACTIVISM, 1500 TO SEE THE, WE
WORK TO VERIFY COSTAR COMMENTS
THAT SHOW THAT DOZENS OF
IRANIANS INCLUDING HIGH-PROFILE
IRANIAN ATHLETES FACE
EXECUTION.
WE ALSO WORK TO VERIFY VIDEO
PLEASE LIKE THIS ONE.
FROM THIS 81-YEAR-OLD MOTHER OF
ONE OF THE DETAINEES.
>> TRANSLATOR: WE DON'T KNOW
HIS WHEREABOUTS.
NO INFORMATION ABOUT HIM, NOR
DO WE KNOW WHERE HE IS.
>> THIS DOCUMENT FROM INSIDE
THE ISFAHAN REGIONAL COURT SHOW
THAT AT LEAST TEN PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN CHARGED WITH MAHATMA, WAR
AGAINST GOD, SPREADING
CORRUPTION ON EARTH AND OTHER
CHARGES, ALL OF WHICH CARRY THE
POSSIBILITY OF THE DEATH
PENALTY.
GO THROUGH OBTAINING AND
VERIFYING COURT DOCUMENTS AND
WITNESS TESTIMONY, WE HAVE
EVIDENCE WHICH SUPPORTS A
RUSHED THROUGH JUDICIAL
PROCESS.
DEFENDANTS HAVING COURT
APPOINTED COUNSEL FORCED ON
THEM.
MANY DEFENDANTS HAVING THEIR
RIGHT TO APPEAL REFUSED, SOME
DEFENDANTS FACED WITH CHARGES
WHICH COULD CARRY THE DEATH
SENTENCE BEING HANDED DOWN IN A
SINGLE SITTING.
TERRIFIED IRANIAN FAMILIES
BELIEVED THAT WHILE THE WORLD
IS BUSY CELEBRATING THE HOLIDAY
SEASON, BUSY WITH THEIR
FAMILIES, THAT THEY, IN IRAN,
FACE IMMINENT EXECUTION OF
THEIR LOVED ONES.
>> >> CNN HAS CONFIRMED THAT --
IS AMONG THOSE FACING
EXECUTION.
HERE HE IS TRAINING AHEAD OF
MATCH DAY.
NOW HE IS ON DEATH ROW WAITING.
THIS IS SOCIAL MEDIA VIDEO FROM
THE NIGHT OF HIS ARREST.
CNN MADE CONTACT WITH SOMEONE
CLOSE TO AN AWESOME ACIDITY,
INSIDE IRAN, WE WILL NOT
DISCLOSING THEIR IDENTITY.
THEY TOLD US THAT IN THE DAYS
AFTER HIS ARREST, THEY WERE
UNABLE TO GET WORD FROM HIM OR
ABOUT HIM FROM AUTHORITIES.
EVEN AS THE IRANIAN AUTHORITIES
DENIED HIS ARREST.
>> TRANSLATOR: IT WAS ONE MONTH
AND 19 DAYS, PERHAPS EVEN
LONGER SINCE THE SECURITY
FORCES CAME AND WANTED TO SEE
HIM HOME.
>> AND DESPITE BEING TOLD HE
WOULD BE FREED.
>> >> TRANSLATOR: THEY WOULD
TELL US IN THE FIRST FEW WEEKS
THAT EMIR WOULD BE FREED IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> AND THEN CAME THE CHARGE OF
THE CRIME OF THE WARM AGAINST
GOD, ALONG WITH HIM AND NINE
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ACCUSED
OF, RELATING TO INVOLVEMENT
KILLING TWO OPERATIVES AND WON
A POLICEMAN DURING PROTESTS IN
LATE NOVEMBER.
A CHARGE THEY DENY.
NOW SOURCES CLOSE TO NASSAR AS
A DONIE SAY THAT HE AND FOUR
OTHERS HAVE HAD THEIR CHARGES
UPGRADED BY THE SVM COURT TO
BODY, A CHARGE PUNISHABLE ONLY
BY EXECUTION.
THERE IS MORE.
IN THE REGIONAL COURT OF
KAZAKHSTAN, WEST OF ISFAHAN,
CNN HAS CONFIRMED THAT 1500
DISAPPEAR THROUGH COURT
DOCUMENTS THAT 23 MORE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH THE SAME
CRIME.
>> PUNISHABLE BY DEATH.
WE ARE ADAPTING THEIR NAMES OUT
OF FEARS FOR THEIR SAFETY.
THERE IS STILL MORE.
IN COTTAGE, CNN AND 1500 TESTS
VIA HAVE CONFIRMED THAT AT
LEAST FIVE MORE IRANIANS ARE
FACING EXECUTION.
INCLUDING 21-YEAR-OLD IRANIAN
KURDISH KARATE CHAMPION,
MOHAMMED MUDDY CADAMY, WHOSE
PARENTS HAVE ALSO GONE PUBLIC
WITH THEIR PLEA.
>> TRANSLATOR: PLEASE, I BEG
YOU TO PLEASE LIFT THE
EXECUTION ORDER FOR MY SON'S
LIFE.
>> IN MESSAGES SHARED WITH CNN,
HIS FAMILY SAY THAT HE WAS NOT
ONLY SENTENCED TO DEATH BUT IS
ALSO BEING TORTURED IN PRISON.
IN ANOTHER MESSAGE SHARED WITH
CNN, THEY SAY CADAMY WAS
SOMEHOW IN GOOD SPIRITS, BUT
PHYSICALLY DAMAGED.
HAVING SUFFERED TORTURE ON HIS
HEAD AND BODY.
BUT INCLUDING THOSE WHOSE
FAMILIES RECORDED PUBLIC PLEAS
FOR HELP, THAT BRINGS THE TOTAL
FOR THOSE VERIFIED BY CNN AS
FACING EXECUTION TO AT LEAST 43
AND THAT IS ADDITION TO THE TWO
EXECUTED BY IRAN AMID THE
EXCITEMENT OF THE WORLD CUP.
JUST THIS WEEK, 27 YEAR OLD
IRANIAN KURDISH RAPPER
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE WHILST IN
DETENTION.
ACCORDING TO A SOURCE FROM THE
PRISON.
A SEAM TRIED TO END HIS LIFE,
SOURCES SAY, WITH PILLS AFTER
ENDURING EXTREME PSYCHOLOGICAL
TORTURE IN THE HARSH PRISON
CONDITIONS IN NORTHERN IRAN.
AS MUCH OF THE WORLD GETS
ABSORBED WITH THEIR FESTIVITIES,
IRANIAN FAMILIES HAVE ONE
MESSAGE.
>> TRANSLATOR: PLEASE SAVE THEM,
FOR THE LOVE OF GOD PLEASE SAVE
MY SONS.
>> CNN, LONDON.
>> WELL CNN SHARE THE FINDINGS
WITH THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND
OFFICIALS ARE RESPONDING, CNN'S
KELLY ATWOOD IS AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WITH MORE ON ALL OF
THIS, AND KELLY, AFTER
VERIFYING THESE DOCUMENTS AND
VIDEOS AND WITNESS TESTIMONY
GATHERED FROM CNN AND THIS
IRANIAN ACTIVIST GROUP, HOW IS
THE STATE DEPARTMENT REACTING
BUT?
>> WELL THE STATE DEPARTMENT
SAYS THEY ARE GRAVELY CONCERNED
ABOUT THESE REPORTS OF MASS
DURESS, TORTURE, IN PRISON AND
THE SHAM TRIALS, THE
CONFESSIONS TO CRIMES GIVEN
UNDER DURESS, AND NOW THESE
DEATH SENTENCES IN SOME CASES
ARE ACTUALLY BEING CARRIED OUT.
SPOKES PERSON'S DEAD THAT A LOT
OF THESE DEATH SENTENCES ARE
HAPPENING AFTER SHAM TRIALS,
WHERE THE IRANIANS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO LAWYERS AND JUST A
FAIR TRIAL GENERALLY SPEAKING.
THEY SAY THAT THIS DEMONSTRATES
THAT THE IRANIAN LEADERSHIP IS
A FEARFUL OF ITS OWN PEOPLE,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
HEARD REPEATEDLY FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT IN RECENT WEEKS, BUT
THIS IS AGAIN HOW THEY ARE
RESPONDING TO THIS
INVESTIGATION REPORTING FROM
CNN.
>> AND KELLY, IN TERMS OF WHAT
ELSE THE U.S. CAN DO, WHAT MORE
CAN BE DONE IN ORDER --
IF ANYTHING REALLY, TO SAVE
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ON DEATH ROW
IN IRAN?
>> I THINK IT IS A GREAT
QUESTION.
I THINK THERE IS REALLY NO EASY
ANSWER TO THAT, THOUGH.
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
INDIVIDUAL CASES, THE ABILITY
OF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO
INTERVENE IS EXTREMELY LIMITED.
BUT WHAT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN DOING, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN DOING,
IS TARGETING SANCTIONS ON
IRANIAN OFFICIALS WHO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE CRACKDOWN.
IRANIANS WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS IN THE
COUNTRY.
THEIR HOPE IS THAT THOSE
SANCTIONS THAT ARE BEGINNING TO
HIT HARD AT THOSE INVOLVED IN
THESE CRACKDOWNS ON PROTESTS,
COULD HAVE SOME SORT OF A
CHILLING EFFECT, COULD HAVE OF
COURSE, HAVE SOME SORT OF
EFFECT THAT WOULD STOP THOSE
INVOLVED FROM CARRYING THIS OUT
DUE TO THE IRANIAN REGIME'S
ORDERS HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL
HAPPEN THOUGH, THAT IS JUST THE
HOPE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEY SAY THAT
WAR SANCTIONS COULD BE COMING
ON THOSE WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
THESE CRACKDOWNS.
>> ALL RIGHT, CARLY ATWOOD FOR
US, THANKS SO MUCH.
AND IF YOU WANT SOME MORE
INFORMATION YOU CAN READ MORE
ON OUR EXCLUSIVE INVESTIGATION
BY GOING TO CNN.COM, CNN'S TEAM,
NIELE ELBAGIR, SELINA HALE, D
AND ARTEMIS MUCH TOGGLE
UNCOVERING THOSE CHILLING
DETAILS INTO THE PLIGHT OF
THOSE SENTENCED TO DEATH INSIDE
IRAN.
SPEAKING WITH SEVERAL OF THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
WE DO ENCOURAGE YOU TO HAVE A
READ FOR MORE ON THIS
DISTURBING, BUT INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT STORY.